To connect your calendar to TungleMe,
you'll need to be signed into your
account. Click calendars and contacts on
the left and then click add new calendar
and contact sync
source. The popup will show you all of
the calendars and social networks that
you can connect
to. Select your calendar type and follow
the simple steps to sync.
For Outlook, Lotus Notes, and Mac
calendars, you'll need to download a
small
connector. Google users will be able to
connect on the web with just an email
address. Once connected, you'll be able
to see your calendar events in your
TongMe account. But don't worry, only
you will be able to see the details of
your calendar. Everything will be kept
private for people viewing your profile
page. which will look something like
this with free busy information only.